[Music]
let's go the jungle is where I'm from
there's no need to be afraid just don't
touch anything we're gonna die out here
or onto something big don't have an
ancient city made of gold those bad guys
are after this get that map oh we just
have to get there first there's no need
to overreact
[Music]
quick what adults cry just don't know
where to look
okay I'm gonna stop being surprised by
the things you're pulling out if your
backpack
don't panic excuse me you know the
jungle it's a part of you but exploring
is not a game and you don't look before
you leap we're on to something big Dora
an ancient city made of gold but about
that and your mother and I are gonna
prove it Amy
I'm sorry sweetie you're not going but
being in the city around kids your own
age like Diego might help are you gonna
get invited some of these party called
ramps the music sounds like this got it
be careful that's what we want to say
cousin Diego you're so skinny and tough
you are way more energetic than I
remember Dora this isn't the jungle it's
high school it's life or death keep a
low profile yes
and just be cool door okay what is this
where did you transfer from the jungle
here's the scavenger hunt list team out
in groups of four hola Dora
you'll help us find your parents and the
lost city of gold where are we all I see
is jungle see three mercenary armed
oh look Dora brought a knife on the
field trip everybody who would maybe you
want to leave I were with your parents
you're all in danger we're gonna die out
here there's no need to overreact of
course she knows this monkey
[Applause]
[Music]
I have to keep going no matter what
she's freaking awesome I think
[Music]
this film is not yet rated Dora for
dinner if you think you know door she'll
grow out of it
think again hey Dora this isn't the
jungle it's high school it's life or
death so if I don't talk to you don't
take a person okay well China suave I
suppose a horrible nightmare
are you I'm glad you brought it I'm just
kidding I don't actually care we're onto
something big Dora an ancient city made
of gold we're gonna break some rules
we're coming with you Prima oh look Dora
brought a knife on the field trip
everybody
it's a jungle puzzle
the jungle is perfectly safe
[Music]
seriously you had that in your backpack
too
don't panic excuse me hey chili con
carne
[Music]